[Music]
we have a device here you believe that
meditation is vital you have often said
that you are in a perpetual state of
meditation is that I am in that state
right now it just means that your body
is dynamic energetic your mind is still
restful alert and your spirit is in a
peaceful place of deep peace and
equanimity what in spiritual traditions
is called to be in the world and not of
it to be in the world or not of it you
have it so I'm not actually here you're
not here right now though this is a
hologram okay all right yeah no just
checking just checking you invented
something called the Dreamweaver that we
have right here tell us blue 2-ton this
is the device they want to show people
there are powerful lights inside this
device yeah you have to keep your eyes
closed when you use it and anyone who
has seizures should not be using it okay
what is with me tonight so I was in a
back with Ricky Gervais is and now I'm
putting on your Caesar glass meditation
alright what happens we put the
headphones on but the earphones oh I
should do that first like here feel them
okay now what it'll do is it'll feed
pulses of light at a certain frequency
yeah about 20 Hertz and then we'll start
to decrease really great forces of light
and your great Oh God
and your brainwaves lock into that and
then slowly we'll decrease the frequency
and as we decrease the frequency your
brainwaves are going to harmony with
those frequencies and you'll go into a
state of dream state actually it's
better than LSD I promise you because
you know this is better than la yeah I
tried LSD in medical school did you try
to LSD in medical school
okay much simpler okay and as your brain
waves going to slow frequencies you're
going to the dream state and ultimately
fall asleep Andy you got to try this on
this is amazing you really go to another
place a place where kittens love puppies
a place where ice cream falls from the
sky a different dimension a different
dimension put that on I just wanted to
see it's very unhygienic
I think this is the strangest show we've
ever done
[Applause]
beep ah this is my 20th year on
television I've been doing this a long
time
that is my journey and this is a freak
show tonight it's absolutely fantastic
what do you think Andy that's great yeah
I like this you like that it is better
than taking a pill you know what the
grace I'm kill and those glasses you
double up man yeah pill in this box
Deepak